hey Sean kennel here host of the top
video marketing virtual experience of
2020 row with video live our world has
gone digital and video has taken over
every aspect of our daily lives and
right now it's time to lean in and learn
how you can take advantage of the power
of video to grow your business build
your brand and make a greater impact
with your message over the past few
months myself and my team have taken in
what's happening in the world and we've
decided that for the health and safety
of our speakers our team and you that
this was the year to change things up
and bring you our sold-out video
conference right to your living room
this is no longer a conference this is
an experience so what does that mean for
you
well the think media team and our lineup
of incredible industry experts will be
joining you on your phone computer or
smart TV
to bring you the best information on how
to dominate on YouTube and across social
media in 2020 and beyond 65 percent of
people use YouTube to help them solve a
problem but when I think about this your
split question all of us need to answer
what problem do you solve you got to
know that and when you know that people
are going to the Internet to go to
Google they go to YouTube to help solve
a problem you need to be showing up with
those answers
[Music]
we are excited to announce that the
groweth video live virtual experience
will be happening
September 8th through the 10th 2020 and
we are bringing you all the energy all
the tactics and the networking online
right to wherever you are in the world
you'll hear from experts dominating on
all video platforms like YouTube
Facebook Instagram LinkedIn and tik-tok
this is not sure everyday conference
just thrown online this is a world-class
experience filled with surprises and
giveaways but also real tangible
learning that will skyrocket your brand
your business your nonprofit or your
side hustle and take it to the next
level our mission here at think media is
to help 10,000 people create a full time
income doing what they love and making
an impact in the world through the power
of online video you know my life has
personally been changed from setting
aside time and committing to going
all-in on learning experiences like this
one when you get around powerful purpose
driven entrepreneurs like yourself
something starts to happen
you start thinking differently and you
start believing for more and I would
venture to say that now more than ever
you need to surround yourself with
people who are striving for change who
are empowered to work for the life that
they want and who have the same kind of
passion to create and build that you do
we may be virtual but the community we
create at these events is more powerful
than the circumstances in the world
right now this community comes together
and lifts each other up and this
conference could not be at a better time
or needed more when you join me
September 8th through the 10th 2020
you'll get three powerful days where we
will give you the roadmap for success
with video my friend I believe that now
is the time for you to go all-in on
video I believe there's no better time
to invest in yourself and in your future
I believe it's time for leaders like you
to rise up and lead movements for change
and for good I believe you can do all of
this when you have the right strategies
and mindset for dominating with
video will do all of this together in
September I'm pumped to see you at grow
with video alive
the virtual experience I am so fired up
and excited if we've never met before my
name is Heather Torres and I am part of
the think media team and I am joined by
Melissa Caputo who is also a part of the
think media team and we are so excited
to announce that groweth video live 2020
is now a virtual experience you just saw
the promo video and Melissa and I are
here to walk through some of the most
frequently asked questions and in here
to help and assist you but Melissa how
excited are you to be throwing a virtual
conference this year oh man Heather I am
so excited we have so many different
activities and just fun little things
that we get to do because this
conference is virtual so I'm so excited
to be exploring all these new options
and this new technology that we're going
to be implementing this year so that's
gonna be so fun and I'm also really
excited just to be able to actually
participate a little bit more in like
meeting people and getting together
because during the live conference I'm
kind of a little bit backstage a lot
more and so this one is gonna be really
fun just for I think our team to be able
to interact so much more with all of our
attendees I know I'm so excited and you
know we have decided to make the
conference virtual that's this year Mel
but we know that we do have people
inside of the think community and what
do they need to do if they've already
purchased tickets to this amazing live
event yes so if you've already purchased
a ticket you should have an email in
your inbox right now that actually
explains to you which new tier so we
have all new tiers with new brand new
perks for this virtual experience and if
you've already purchased your ticket you
have been automatically granted into
your brand new ticket your brand new
tier for the virtual experience that's
all done for you you actually don't need
to do anything there's no claim process
that you have to go through we've done
that
all for you all we want you to do is
check your email so that you can know
which perks exactly you get and so
everybody has a different ticket that
they purchased and so we actually can't
answer here in the chat which perks are
which tier you are in so you have to
check your email in order to get that
information and if you need any help
finding that email or you know figuring
out exactly what it all means then you
can definitely email our team at hello
at Sean kennel comm to get that info yes
and I already see it in the chat right
now Mel how do they go and get tickets
how do they join us for this virtual
experience let's break down some of the
tiers that we have available
yes definitely so first thing is head
right to grow with video live.com all of
this information is there for you um you
know you can watch that video again
because it gets me pumped so I just kind
of watch it I'm not kidding I genuinely
love the music and love the content in
it so you'll also see these three tiers
for our conference when you get to grow
with video live.com so if you can see if
you are a general admission if you just
want to jump in at that level you'll get
access to all of our main sessions and
all the main content and you'll also
have access to that content until
September 12 so just a pause for a
second our conference is happening at
the same time as our live conference was
scheduled and so it is happening on
September 8th through 10th is when our
main sessions are going to be taking
place but if you are international or
you're worried that you might not be
able to make it because we are gonna be
on los angeles time for the conference
then you'll have access to those replays
through September 12th if you would like
to have access to those a little bit
longer you can jump into our premier
tier where you'll have access until
November 12th and if you just want to
lock it in and make sure that you're
able to jump back into these sessions at
any time it will actually have that
available as lifetime access for our
ultimate tier now we have so many more
benefits also for our premier and our
ultimate members so I'm just going to
touch on a couple of those really
briefly for all of our tears we will
have a workbook and we will have those
main sessions but for our premier and
ultimate tiers you're going to get
access to either
in more session so we're gonna have
special breakout sessions that will be
small groups where we can really niche
down into the content that we're talking
about we can discuss things we can
answer questions and we can just dig
into it all together and so as a premier
or an ultimate member you'll have access
to some of those sessions if you want
access to every session to all the
different content to bonus opportunities
to meet with our speakers and meet with
our team you'll be able to get that in
the ultimate tier you'll also get
special Q&A sessions as part of that
ultimate tier so that is one of the
biggest perks there are other things on
there we have a pop-up shop we have
going on if you want to jump into the
ultimate group you get a digital swag
bag that has really like really amazing
perks in it I'm not announcing I'm not
gonna spill it all but we have really
cool things that are gonna be in that
swag bag you get $25 to our exclusive
think media pop-up shop that'll only be
available for the growth video live
conference attendees so there's a bunch
of other stuff in there
check out these tiers and you can get
all the details I grow this video
live.com but if I just want to reiterate
if you want that close intimate
interaction jump in to the ultimate
group or even just the premier group and
that's where we're gonna have even those
those breakout sessions and we're gonna
really get to hang out with you guys
more yes now Melissa you know you have
been to several conferences over the
last couple years and there's just
something special about virtual
conferences I know people are asking is
this still fun how do we do community
how do we get to meet each other like
what does this look like and if you know
the think media team you know that we
love community and we love to
over-deliver with the amount of value
that's happening so we've only just
scratched the surface of talking about
some of the benefits of grabbing your
ticket right now for growth with video
live but Melissa will it still be fun if
you're sitting at your own house looking
at the computer screen how does this
work how do we do this yes okay yeah
that is that's the answer yes it will
still be fun and as Heather mentioned we
as a team go above and beyond to serve
you guys and so we are putting all of
our brains together as I mentioned we're
researching the newest technology the
newest
different things that are coming out for
virtual conferences in order to make
this highly interactive and just fun we
just want it to be fun we of course want
you to get tons of value out of this we
want you to build collaborations that
are gonna last we want you to walk away
with a game plan for your YouTube
channel but we also want this to be fun
we want this to be something where
you're sitting in your room and you're
laughing to yourself if your roommates
or your husband or whoever else around
it's like what is going on that's what
that's the response that we're trying to
work towards for this conference and we
have some really fun as I mentioned like
games and activities that we're gonna be
seating throughout the conference in
order to make that happen but also I
just want to emphasize how powerful
being in a chat with being on a video
like this in a chat for three days and
actually more as Heather mentioned
there's there's a lot more you can check
it out on the website we'll have pre
conference calls as well to meet each
other and networking parties etc but
being with the same group of people in
the chat and having the opportunity to
see people's names go by and see people
answering questions and you know talking
about fun things as well as the content
is really a great way to build
connections and personally for a lot of
us it might actually even be easier than
a live event because you're gonna have
the opportunity to speak to so many more
people than perhaps you would at a live
event and now trust me I love live
events and I think it's great and I'm so
excited for future years when that
becomes a thing again but this is gonna
have so many different perks and so many
different opportunities and so if you've
been a part of any of our like our
YouTube challenge group or any of those
other times when we've just spent time
in a chat room together watching the
same content you know the kind of bond
that it builds we have inside jokes
we've got stuff always it just happens
we don't try it just happen so I am
really excited for that experience other
yeah and one of the things that if you
know Sean Connell if you know me if you
know Melissa if you know any of our
think media coaches you know that our
heart is to teach our heart is to help
our heart is to serve and so one of the
questions that we knew we were going to
get is well will I still learn as much
being that it's a virtual
conference and what does that look like
and I can guarantee you that one of the
things that we do here at think media
different than almost all other
conferences out there is that we really
curate the content that's going to be
delivered
Nadiya not only just what they think
media team is going to be teaching on
but even what our speakers are gonna be
teaching on we want to make sure that
you're walking away with a game plan
that you've got tangible actionable
steps that you're getting inspiration
motivation as well as mindset and this
is for everyone who wants to dominate
using video and that means on not just
YouTube but on LinkedIn and Facebook and
tik-tok and Instagram and all of the
ways that we have not only grown our
business but all of our industry experts
speakers and friends have grown their
businesses and so for us we really make
sure that we're curating the right type
of experience for you and like Melissa
said you'll get a handbook that goes
along with the conference that you can
print out at home that you can have with
you you can walk through it and I'm just
so excited because we because this is a
virtual conference like Melissa leaked a
little bit we have things happening not
only just during the conference but even
before the conference and even after and
so we are so excited because what you're
gonna want to walk away with is the game
plan is the tangible pieces that will
help you grow your channels that will
help you get better at video that will
help you understand the gear all of
those pieces and components we know are
so important to being able to do this
and so I am so excited that this year it
can go around the world because if you
know us here at think media our heart is
to help change the world with video and
so now we get to come right to your
living room right to your office right
to your computer right to your phone
right to your tablet and teach you where
you are and I cannot wait for September
8th through 10th you can get at grow
with video live and if you're just
joining us we just announced that this
year's conference is now a virtual
experience happening the same dates 8th
through 10th and if you've already
purchased a ticket or you've claimed
your ticket
our website we've already sent you an
email with an upgraded experience so we
are so excited for you to be a part of
this and anything else I'm forgetting
Melissa because I'm just like way
excited about what is happening I'm
seeing the chat people are excited
someone said they're from Hawaii and
they were afraid to travel someone else
said I wasn't thinking about going but
now I'm going someone said can I upgrade
I am so excited for this community to
come together in September and launch
into 2021 with the newest game plan with
the newest action steps for how to
dominate with video yes how that I think
you covered all of the biggest points of
it if you guys want to know more details
about what's included on all those tiers
had to grow as video live.com we would
love to have you all join us let's make
this the biggest baddest video
conference of 2020 I don't know if I've
ever referred to any of our stuff as the
baddest I don't know if that's a thing
anymore just came out but if they have
questions though where can they go you
see some questions in the chat right now
and if you're watching this video on the
replay we're here for you we want to
help you and we have a whole support
team behind us for this conference
helping you get the right ticket for you
so Melissa what's the best way for them
to get a hold of us if they have
questions or need to know anything about
their tickets or the experience yes so
if you have a question about your ticket
because you've already purchased a
ticket and you haven't seen your email
or you're just unclear about the email
email hello at Sean kennel comm that is
the best way for us to help you get all
of that cleared up we promise you we are
taking care of you if you've purchased a
ticket you are set so do not panic if
you're not seeing that email it's gonna
be okay we're gonna talk with talk it
through with you and hello as Sean
kennel comm if you have any other
questions and if you want to talk with
somebody through the different tiers or
have asked a couple questions before you
jump in then you can also email us at
hello is Sean kennel comm and we would
love to help clarify anything for you
and if you just want to dive in right
now because you're seeing how awesome
this is going to be then it's grow with
video live.com and there's actually a
chat feature on that page so that will
be the best ways to get ahold of us yes
and we are so excited we're gonna sign
off for tonight but if you have
additional questions you can leave them
here in the chat or over in the chat
wherever you are watching this video in
the chat you can leave that for us or
email us at Sean at hello at Sean
Channel calm thank you so much for
watching today and we'll catch you in
the next video you can get your tickets
right now at groweth video live.com bye